everyone welcome back to another video
by simply learn in this video we will
discuss some of the top universities in
the world why they are so popular and
why you should study there additionally
we will learn how to apply to these
universities the criteria and much more
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
press the bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
let's start with the first university
eth zurich swiss federal institute of
technology one of the top universities
in the world for technology and the
natural sciences is eth zurich it is
renowned for its top-notch instruction
fundamentally transformative research
and for applying its most recent
discoveries right away
eth zurich which was founded in 1855
currently enrolls about 18 000 students
from over 100 different nations
the fields of engineering architecture
mathematics natural science
system-oriented science management and
social science are currently taught and
researched by about 500 professors now
let's understand top reasons to study in
eth zurich facilities like loans and
grants are available for existing
students various scholarships open to
international students at bachelor's
master's and doctoral levels are one of
the reason to study in eth zurich
like botanical garden etf zurich devotes
its resources to creating a climate that
fosters the development of global talent
and innovation at all organizational
levels the institution's bottom-up
culture promotes high level of autonomy
and accountability such a culture
attracts the best of the best and offers
the ideal setting for originally
motivated people however eth zurich's
outstanding graduates and aluminized who
number over 65 thousands have formed
more than 400 spin-off businesses
including pragnolia and talalatix now
we'll understand
how to apply for eth zurich there are
two application windows for eth
bachelor's program
regular
starts from 1 november to 30 april late
1 may to 31 july
then apply online at e-apply for the
bachelor's degree program of your choice
you will receive step-by-step
instructions as you complete the online
application you must print out the
application form fill it out and sign it
before mailing add the admission office
by the deadlines in order for your
application to be accepted
then your application will be processed
after paying an application fee
now let's understand about imperial
college london so imperial college
london founded in 1907 is the only
institution in united kingdom to
strongly emphasize science engineering
medicine and business
it is a top public research university
here 100 undergraduate courses from
imperial college london and 150 masters
programs are available
the university represents 140 different
nations over 17 000 students of whom 50
percent are imperial college london
foreign students
now let's discuss the top reasons to
study at imperial college london
so imperial college london has received
the gold teaching excellence framework
that is tef
it is an award for its exceptional
student accomplishments in education and
learning
out of all the universities in the
united kingdom imperial graduates earn
the highest average beginning wage
it offers a variety of imperial college
scholarship to deserving students and is
one of the uk's universities with the
most general financial aid policies
students who exhibit academic aptitude
are given a scholarship worth
one thousand euro inr 80 000 every year
for up to four years
now we will understand how to apply to
imperial college london to be eligible
for admission to imperial college london
certain procedures must be undertaken
lie to ucas portal this is for
undergraduate college online system and
pro schedule then fill up your details
upload the required documents and pay
the application fee
so this is a simple procedure to apply
for imperial college london now as we
have understood about imperial college
london now let's understand about
california institute of technology which
is also known as caltech founded in 1891
the prestigious california institute of
technology is a private research
university caltech which is based in
pasadena has established a reputation as
one of the world's top technological
universities naturally a sizable number
of applications are submitted worldwide
including thousands from india it is
difficult to enter though now
let's discuss the top reasons to study
at caltech so many of the premier
scientific research institutions in the
world such as nasa's jet propulsion lab
and the paloma and cac observatories are
either located at caltech or are under
its management caltech housing is a
special combination of the conventional
and the novel
the caltech dorms are described as
self-burning living spaces with student
waiters for suppers and even a first
year sorting somewhere between
fraternity and hogwarts house
now
let's understand how to apply at
california institute of technology first
year applicants in this both u.s and
international students have to complete
the common application or collision
application along with the following
submissions common application or
collision application powered by square
or common application collation
application with supplemental
application assays there are few
additional requirements for
international students like english
proficiency exam scores like toefl ielts
det are the acceptable english
proficiency exams
international financial aid statement of
intent
now the transfer admission so caltech
welcomes a small number of transfer
students
following are the admissions
requirements like 75 dollar application
fee entrance examinations self-proctored
form
maths and physics and trend examinations
two college faculty evaluations transfer
report form
official transcripts from all college
universities attended then official
transcripts from your secondary school
we have understood how to apply at
california institute of technology
so now let's understand about harvard
university
was founded in 1636 and is a private
league research institution one of the
most prominent colleges in the world it
is known for its richness prestige and
history within harvard university there
is a close-knit undergraduate community
called hardwood college so harvard is
more than just a place to receive an
education it offers world-class faculty
groundbreaking research opportunities
and a dedication to a diverse
environment of bright talented students
harvard's campus resources are unmatched
and includes arts athletics service
libraries and museum collections now
let's discuss the top reasons to study
at harvard university so financial aid
officers at harvard will ensure that
your lack of ability to pay is not a
barrier from attending the university
despite the very generous financial aid
package they offer a piece of bazooka
bubblegum can cost less than a harvard
education there are excessively many
resources available at harvard first off
with 17 million books and 55 miles of
shelving
the harvard library system is the
world's largest private library system
beyond libraries harvard has a lot of
funding available to support your
research study abroad or a combination
of the two in my perspective harvard has
the best of all worlds because it is a
city a college town and its own college
harvard has its own complete campus
while being only a short distance from
boston so now let's discuss how to apply
for harvard university so to apply for
harvard university you must give the act
or sat set exam
after that again you have to give set
two particular exam following that there
is a toefl exam in which the english
proficiency is checked you also need to
have a letter of recommendation from the
two teachers who have taught you
documents including 10th and 12th mark
sheet etc you have to submit and they
also check regarding the extracurricular
activities so if you have participated
in any extracurricular activity then you
have to submit the details of that
following that you have to write an
essay that you have achieved and what
you want to achieve and why you want to
join harvard when all of these documents
are with you then you can apply from two
methods first is early action and the
second is regular decision in early
action you have to apply before 1
november and in regular decision you
have to apply before 1 january for
admission you can apply from 3 methods
first is common application the second
is collision application and the third
is universal college application portal
if you get selected then you have to
give an interview which can be online or
some of their alumni will come and take
your interview so this was the procedure
to get into harvard now let's go ahead
and understand about university of
cambridge
the institution of cambridge was founded
in 1209 and is a public university in to
harvard now let's go ahead and
understand about university of cambridge
the institution of cambridge was founded
in 1209 and is a public university in
cambridge england the university which
is the third oldest in the world has
constantly ranked among the top five it
includes 31 constituent colleges 100
departments split into 6 schools
focuses mostly on educating the
humanities and social science biological
science clinical medicine physical
science and technology so now let's
discuss the top reasons to study at
university of cambridge cambridge has a
lot of culture to its name for such a
little city it has numerous museums in
addition to the prominent art spaces
like the cambridge junction and the corn
exchange the museum is home to stunning
artifacts from ancient egypt medieval
weapons and armor and more the city and
the nearby towns and villages
make up high-tech hub known as silicon
fan when it comes to stem sector
cambridge punches much above its weight
thanks to the established pharmaceutical
research facilities as well as tech
startups
let's understand how to apply at
university of cambridge so first is
course selection
to choose a course you are personally
interested in and will thoroughly like
to study because you will be studying at
a very high level for several years
second will be application submission to
apply for ucas you must do so earlier or
later deadlines may apply for mature
students foundation year and oregon
scholarship applicants if you are
applying for the graduate course in
medicine there is supplementary
application form the universities of
cambridge and oxford cannot accept
applications in the same calendar year a
transcript of records will be sought
from some applicants then there is
written assessment so the majority of
applicants must complete a written
admission test so if you are selected
for an interview your chosen cambridge
college will organize some assessments
while others require you to register in
advance through an authorized assessment
center then there is interview everyone
with a good chance of being offered a
place is invited to attend an interview
so as we have understood about the
university of cambridge let's go ahead
and understand about stanford university
so located in stanford california the
well-known stanford university is a
private research institution with a
significant out simply put if someone
says accepted to stanford they should
accept it without question because of
the uni's low acceptance rate of just
4.8 percent and its generous financial
aid policies you need to look no further
than the vast list of well-known
businessmen started by stanford alumini
like google have led parker linkedin
yahoo and sun microsystems to get an
understanding of just how competitive
stanford is now
let's have a look at the top reasons to
study in stanford university so stanford
is a home to some of the best professors
in the world with the top academics in a
range of subjects stanford recently
ranked among the top five colleges in
united states news and world's report's
most current list of the top value
colleges
which takes into account both the cost
of attendance and academic standards
stanford should be inexpensive for the
majority of students even though the
school promotes its total cost as being
over 60 thousand dollars
now the social life at stanford
university so students assemble every
fall quarter for a full moon on the quad
a drunken welcome from the upper class
men to the new freshmen and to check out
the geek scene at sigma alpha epsilons
back to school start or kappa alpha's
roaming nomad party and there are
numerous other reasons to study at
stanford university some of the top
courses at stanford are
artificial intelligence biocomputing
bioinformatics and biotechnology
computer systems cyber security data
analytics mobile or web application
software engineering
so now
let's understand how to apply at
stanford university
so you must use either the common
application or the coalition application
to apply to stanford as a freshman your
act or sat scores must be submitted
a school report a report from your
guidance counselor to teacher
recommendations official transcripts and
a mid-year transcript for your senior
year are also required for your
application file in the collision
application you will be given access to
stanford questions after you have
finished submit your application by the
deadline required for the process you
have chosen so this is how you can apply
for stanford university
now let's understand about the
university of oxford
so the university of oxford is a
university research institution with 38
constituent colleges that principally
impart knowledge in the areas of
technology biology clinical medicine
physical science and the humanities and
social science it is the oldest english
speaking university in the world
although the exact year of its founding
is unknown now let's have a look at the
top reasons to study at university of
oxford
so oxford university is a well-known for
its outstanding academic facilities
gives its undergraduate students the
chance to join one of the world's most
renowned and respected faculties as well
as close-knit academic community oxford
also ensures that no deserving candidate
is passed over due to financial
difficulties as a result it provides its
students with financial aid like
scholarship programs
oxford university degree is highly
valued by the employers in the
employment market the civil service law
banking the arts and publishing are
among the industries where jobs are most
prevalent according to studies now let's
look at the application process for the
university of oxford so first of all
choose the course
you must make this choice first and
foremost so consider all of your
possibilities carefully your time at
university will be a lot more
pleasurable if you are studying
something you truly enjoy step would be
choose a college so choose whether you
want to submit an open application or
one of the preference for a certain
college then the admission test these
are a critical part of many courses
evaluation process by september 30th
make sure you are enrolled and have your
test candidate entry number then there
is ucas application to apply for
admittance in 2023 begin working on your
ucas application as early as june and
submit it by october 15th 2022 after
that there would be interviews like in
december 2022 candidates who made the
cut for admittance in 2023 will be
participating in an online interview
then the decision on january 10 2023
those who have been interviewed will
learn if they have been given a place
then their results your support will be
guaranteed once you have gotten your
exam results and fulfilled the
requirements for your offer so this was
the procedure to apply at the university
of oxford one of the most elite
universities
now let us understand about mit
the private business school of mit is
known as the massachusetts institute of
technology or more commonly known as mit
sloan school of management
at mit there are graduate and
undergraduate programs accessible there
are five academic institutions the
whitetaker college of health science and
technology the school of architecture
and planning
the school of engineering
school of humanities
arts and social science now let's
discuss the top reasons to study in mit
so international enrollment at the
massachusetts institute of technology is
remarkable this is as a result of
outstanding advantages it provides to
its students mit hopes to draw and
welcome a large number of well-known
corporations including facebook google
microsoft amazon and others after
graduation there is a significant rate
of placement changes with these
companies for the student who have
direct exposure to them so as we have
understood the top reasons to study in
mit now we will understand how to apply
for mit so the student must submit all
of the necessary paperwork for their
chosen program at once fill out the
application form with your information
and then submit your bachelor's degree
or equivalent transcripts after that for
some courses the students are required
to provide documentation of their
microeconomics or accounting background
in order to complete their application
student must provide supplemental
materials and then submit the
application fee wherever applicable this
was the procedure to apply for mit
so these were some of the top
universities of the world providing
top-notch education outstanding chances
for research and significant industrial
exposure in practically every field of
study with that we have come to the end
of this video so if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up i hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here